have you always wanted to be into
modeling the both of you
um i started in 1992 and i just entered
a modeling competition literally it was
a coupon and a magazine i filled it out
sent in some vacation pictures
what i entered this contest and i won
yeah that was in 1992.
so i never even thought that was a job i
literally just i was like okay i'll try
i send my pictures and let's see what
happens
and it was on a tv show it went on for
six months like i had to win the week
the month and then i won the end it was
you lived a movie that sounds like a
movie that doesn't sound like your life
it was just a fluke
um but the reason why i asked too
especially you heidi is because i know
that you're
was it your first cover it was my
glamour cover
my daughter just did 20 years later 20
years later
that's what i was saying like that's
amazing yeah i did the first cover for
them
and they just asked you know my daughter
if she wanted to do it i also went to
that shoot my mom came because we did it
in germany it was for german glamour
yeah and it's just so much fun to see
her and she's just like a butterfly she
just loves to like
dance around and have fun she's not
intimidated but it's also because she's
followed me to
all of my shoots and all of you know
also the tv
sets and everything you're kind of like
you're welcome so yeah cause you got the
lay of the land before you had to
very very lucky work so blessed fine
with the camera like looking into it you
know
that's the main fate of it i did not get
that from my mother at all my mother
hates the camera she doesn't like to be
in front of it at all
my mom doesn't like it either but yeah
my mom is totally she would never if i'd
said oh if you could just stand on stage
and just she'd be like
no no yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever